not well known publicly but lord david
frost was a crucial part of boris
johnson's government
in charge of the brexit talks he
negotiated the withdrawal agreement and
the trade deal with the eu but he's now
resigned citing unhappiness with high
taxes the focus on net zero and covered
restrictions
in his resignation letter to the prime
minister lord frost said you know my
concerns about the current direction of
travel i hope we will move as fast as
possible to where we need to get to a
lightly regulated low tax
entrepreneurial economy while on the
covert rule changes he said you took a
brave decision in july against
considerable opposition to open up the
country again sadly it did not prove to
be irreversible
at the end of a rocky week for downing
street that seen a back bench rebellion
and by-election loss this was the last
thing the prime minister needed
this is just the latest um example of
the government just being all over the
place not just on brexit but on covid
and
i think the lack of leadership the lack
of clarity the lack of steadiness in the
cabinet is what's it ultimately uh
what's led to david frost making this
quite extraordinary decision on a
saturday night
lord frost's exit also throws the
ongoing brexit negotiations into
uncertainty talks are due to resume with
the eu in the new year amid briefing
that the uk could be about to alter its
position on northern ireland
what boris johnson does next matters
lord frost was seen by brexiteers as a
guardian of brexit if he's replaced by
someone who's perceived as a softer
touch then that could anger the very mps
who are already beginning to lose faith
in the prime minister
already leaked whatsapp messages show
anxiety among some conservatives with
one describing lord frost's exit as a
disaster and another saying it's a
hammer blow to the prime minister
whoever takes over now is going to have
to be just as strong and just as tough
with the european union because the
european union is not going to give in
on this unless they are really
show that the united kingdom government
means what it says
boris johnson goes into christmas week
hobbled on many fronts and faced with
tough decisions over covered regulations
for now ministers seem intent on waiting
for more data before potentially
tightening restrictions but events have
weakened the prime minister at the worst
possible moment
rob powell sky news in westminster